sounds like you both reached a certain
point where you couldn't see the movie
clearly enough and you knew that not
just the three of you your editor
included yes you needed a fresh set of
eyes do you know at what point like how
long was that into the process how many
was i was September so we started on
Valentine's Day right no so so it was
however many months I was six months
seven months it was like once we do have
it in time once we had all of our chunks
you know all of our sequences and we
strung them together in a way that felt
plausible um then we had our first
rough-cut screening and it was just for
producer and for a couple of other phone
makers and artists that were close to
the be new us like really well it wasn't
like we didn't open it out to colleagues
necessarily and her husband um and and
so we thought was like our first you
know that was the three-hour one like
what's working what's not working where
you know what where are you do you see a
filming yeah yeah and it was a relief
that was like better that went better
than we sort of thought and then we then
we tried to you know wind our way a
little bit more and we had total one two
three four of them for total it was just
trying to cut out that last like 25
minutes which was the hardest it was so
hard we were submitting the film to set
to you know film festivals and and
trying to get it to a point that was
workable for a programmer to what you
know it was really hard so those last 25
minutes for yeah that was painful yeah
painful
you